[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday October
23rd it sieved you and I as Brotherhood
2.0 has some explaining to do on several
counts first we've got my lipstick I ate
a blue lollipop and it's not washing off
not actually lipstick I promise
second people seem to be very surprised
that I was driving so much last week and
they were confused that I was driving to
Seattle just to get on a plane but if
you live in Montana you understand the
data sometimes of necessity because it
is impossible to fly to some places from
Missoula without paying thousands of
dollars so instead
Katherine and I drove like eight hours
to Seattle so we can see some friends
hang out and then get on an airplane to
Georgia which is where we are now to see
some friends get married you might
recognize these friends as the duo who
assisted us in will you miss me when I'm
gone from your pants this is the back of
one of their heads and he's not turning
around
even though I'm fairly certain that he
knows that I'm talking about him Bryan
Bryan
oh well third thing that we have to
explain about I think is my aversion to
tattoos very sort of the people who were
offended by my statements that sometimes
people begin to resent their tattoos
later in life understand that having a
tattoo is a personal choice I have not
made that choice for myself I could
someday maybe decide that I need a
tattoo to explain some part of my life
to celebrate some joy to put something
behind me but I've never had the urge um
because I'm not really in favor of
paying for things that hurt also I feel
like having a tattoo puts you in a club
and people can make judgments about that
club boo tattoos a guy s tattoos
I must means he like to cut the nuts off
to little kittens one of my hopes in
life is to minimize visual cues by which
people can judge me obviously I'm not a
hundred percent good at that
I wear funny t-shirts have dark rimmed
glasses I'm wearing blue lollipop
lipstick but all in all I feel like I
would rather people judge me by what I
say and how I act than what I look like
and what is tattooed across my knuckles
now obviously the judgment being made
against people with tattoos is not the
fault of the people with tattoos but
sometimes it's worth screwing with ways
interfering with my video blogging
anyway I think you get the point
sometimes it's just not worth joining
the team and while I might not actually
take a huge amount of pride in my place
at the head of Team Unicorn I am quite
proud of my involvement in team science
the idea of science is that you take a
bunch of factors and then you work
towards a solution predation ISM sort of
is the exact opposite where you have the
solution because some guy came up with
it hundreds of years ago and then you
work towards making everything explain
that solution I'm assuming John that
that's what you meant when you said that
young Earth Creationism was rampantly
anti-intellectual or something you kept
saying that in the comet and I just
wanna let you know that unlike the
zombies and unicorns thing I'm with you
on that but what dangerous is getting on
the teams and then getting angry to each
other because that's what high school
rivalries are about and that's what holy
wars are about and those are two things
that I'm just not a real big fan of in
that spirit I want to leave you with
story Katie and Emma went to the same
high school and they thought they were
the only nerdfighters I thought high
school and then Katie and Emma found
each other and they found out that they
were nerdfighters and now they are
stronger because they are nerdfighters
together and that is what matters it's
not fighting against it is joining up
and that's what nerdfighter earnest is
about I don't want people to be pissed
off about what I believe because in the
end John it's just me talking to you
don't forget to be awesome I'll see you
tomorrow
these two are married it's taken a lot
of time for my family to come to terms
with it it's an age difference mostly
hey you guys need to eight to realize
he's like 40-something yes bad fry she
can you taught me look it's a new kitty
this is Robin say how hard in here that
Robin